[Musique]
le discours a été prononcé devant des
membres des forces de sécurité réunies
au Kremlin
72 heures après la fin de la rébellion
du groupe Wagner Vladimir Poutine a tenu
à remercier les militaires qui selon lui
ont empêché une guerre civile en Russie
vous avez agi avec justesse et cohérence
dans une situation difficile vous avez
prouvé votre loyauté envers le peuple
russe en honorant votre serment
militaire vous avez fait preuve de
responsabilité quant au sort de la
patrie et à son avenir
le maître du Kremlin le sait il lui faut
vite reprendre la main au risque de voir
son pouvoir se fragiliser encore un peu
plus il joue alors la carte de l'unité
nationale et la sueur ni l'armée
régulière ni la population russe non
soutenu la rébellion armée
quelques minutes plus tard cette fois-ci
dans son bureau Vladimir Poutine
s'attaque à son ancien allié Eve gany
Prigogine le patron de Wagner objectif
le décrédibiliser il avance alors des
chiffres selon lui entre mai 2022 et mai
2023 le groupe paramilitaire aurait reçu
près d'un milliard d'euros de la part de
l'État russe le président Poutine promet
alors une enquête pour savoir comment a
été dépensé cet argent
j'espère qu'ils n'ont rien volé ou
qu'ils n'ont pas beaucoup volé
ce qui est certain c'est que nous allons
faire toute la lumière dessus
une épine de plus dans le pied d'eph
guni Prigogine désormais personna non
grata en Russie il est arrivé ce mardi
en Biélorussie si l'on en croit le
président le cash and co
et